so we just had hands-on time with
battlefield hardline we both played
multiplayer we were both on the
criminals team and we played the new hot
wire mode what did you think about well
first of all I think our team would have
done a lot better had we cooperated
together it was pretty much every man
for themselves in the criminal in the
criminals team that tends to happen in a
battlefield game though people sort of
just wander off to do their own thing
that's right although at one point I did
see what you were up to and I followed
you around without you realizing was me
and I hopped in the back of the car you
were driving exactly so the whole point
of this game mode is taking the
traditional conquest mode where you need
to capture these static flags and in
Hotwire those flags are actually cars so
you get in the car and you're
essentially capturing that car and to
continue getting points from it you have
to drive it around above a certain speed
if you drop below that speed you no
longer get points from it so there's
this kind of Perpetual car chase that's
happening across the map that's right
and although like I think what what
really slowed down gameplay for that was
everyone was kind of doing their own
thing but at the same time that also
applied to like the criminals and the
the cops as well like um you know they
were also driving around in their cop
cars looping around in circles around
the map and apples really strange
because no one was really kind of going
for the same objective at the same time
that means that it was really fun
shooting at cop cars so I was in the
enforcer I believe there were a couple
of classes or roles that you could play
and I was toting a shotgun and just
running around and like shooting at cop
cars which would explode and like you
know a huge blast of color when you
happened and you were saying before like
you could actually get in the passenger
side of my van that I was driving around
and trying to capture and one of the new
things you can do is you can press the
third person view button and he actually
gets out and leans out the window and
starts aiming you know sort of like a
wants to move like heat or something and
it's really cool because it allows you
to actually perform a function in the
passenger seat whereas typically you'll
just be sitting there and waiting to you
know get off yeah and I wasn't really
just limited to that one
being either like you know you pressing
X allowed me to shift around the van in
different positions so at one point I
was in the passenger seat pointing out
with a gun and then another point I like
opens the doors of the back of the van
and actually was that the back like
shooting at the back there as well and
of course like you could see that
because you were driving into third
person view and you can see me popping
in a hundred different places in the van
were you actually doing damage to the
cop cars because one of the things is
there's very few explosives in this game
mode and that's kind of a way to extend
the car chases because typically
explosives killer vehicle in one hit so
what were you actually doing when you
were shooting at them did you feel like
you were accomplishing something well
you know I was mainly using the shotgun
and I felt like well far away you can't
really do that much damage and you are
only equipped with one grenade um in the
build that we were playing so once they
tossed a grenade out then went nowhere I
was kind of like that was it so I did
have to rely on like you know shooting
lovely on that I was using and it didn't
feel effective actually once we got
close enough it had to be within a
certain range otherwise other than that
like if you were really far away you
really had to rely on the driver to get
you close enough to do the damage that
you needed to do right yeah I was being
the driver for most of the session and I
did find that I was trying to think
about positioning myself based on who
was popping out my windows and who they
were firing at which is actually really
hard to do but I did find that the map
was actually pretty small and not big
enough for the kind of game mode that
they want we ended up just doing loops
of sort of the perimeter of the map in
maybe less than a minute and I mean the
idea is that they want this kind of
Perpetual car chase to happen but you
just don't have the physical space to do
that in well it's funny you say that
because I actually felt the officer I
thought the map was actually just right
in terms of size because all over the
time when i spawned iceporn near
vehicles that you can't get into every
single car you know you have to walk
towards it and then if the prompt pops
up saying they hold square to get in the
vehicle then you know oh I can get into
this car it's not just decorative so not
every single vehicle was available for
you to get into and so because of that a
lot of the time I was running around
like chasing other people's vehicles
trying to be like hey let me think i'll
pick me up you and I was flagging on
like the the Viper you know the voice
prompt or the chat prompt as well like I
need a ride I know
what he did that you know and also
because of that the map was just the
right size with someone who was stranded
on foot to be running around and
shooting at things and still being like
I need arrived I feel like the the more
fun role there is being the passenger
and shooting out of the window because
you don't really need to pay attention
to the fact that oh I'm at this part of
the map I've got to turn around again
you're sort of just focusing on actually
shooting the pursuing police vehicles
and as long as you're continually on the
move you still get that cool car chase
sensation at sort of fantasy
I